what are those exactly lines are keep
seeing on videos on YouTube make me ones
like this so you can see on the BBC's
News Ticker here we've got this like
this sort of combing Ziggy zaggy effect
on the video what's going on there well
this is an interesting problem the basic
problem is that computer people don't
understand video what you're seeing
there is an artifact of the way that the
video systems are put together in the
30s when they develop the first video
systems they were designing them using
analog electronics remember this is
about 10 years before the first computer
was invented the first electronic
computer was invented so they're having
to develop the video system using pure
analog electronics and so they had to
make sensible design decisions at that
time to encode the video so they could
transmit it and get it to people's homes
where they could then watch it on their
television screens that's all well good
but we've got modern computers and we've
been to the moon in fact since then why
if we got was exactly lies and obvious
well we'll come to that well let's
actually look at what is actually
happening how these things are put
together now Sean's helpfully given me a
bit of computer listing paper which is
great because it's divided into lines so
the way that the image was built up is
that every 50 millisecond and we talked
about in the previous video why you need
to do it at 50 frames per second to get
decent motion rendition the camera would
scan the image from the top left to the
bottom right and it would go along the
first line swing back to the beginning
and go along the next line swing back
and then go on the next one and so on
until eventually it comes to the end at
which point it goes back up to the
beginning of the frame and starts doing
the same thing but there's a problem the
amount of data that is generated
scanning what was 405 line TV back in
1936 in the UK that 50 frames per second
was too much that could be reliably
transmitted with the technology at the
time there's too much information that
you need to transmit too much bandwidth
will be taken up so they needed to do
something they couldn't go down to 25
frames per second because then it would
flicker like crazy as we talked about in
the last video so they couldn't reduce
the frame rate they said I just shoot at
50 frames per second to get the
frame rate so they came up with a trick
which they call interlacing so if we
start again if we call the first one
aligned one the second one is line two
three four five and so on what they said
was we will transmit first line one so
you scan across line one like so and
then we'll skip over line two and
transmit line three
so we fly back and we transmit line
three and then we skip over the line
four and transmit Lyme five and so you
do all that until you get down to the
bottom of the image so you're
transmitting only the odd-numbered line
so in that 50 of a second wasn't saying
the whole frame you only send every
other line or half the frame and they
refer to that as a field and then you go
back and scan the even numbered lines so
2 4 6 8 and so on so you'd scan all the
evening lines in the next 50 of a second
so what you actually ended up doing you
send your first field which will be all
the odd lines and then a 50 of a second
later you're sending the second field
which that got all the even lines in it
and then you're sending the third field
which has got all the odd lines in it
again and so on so you're sending all
the odd lines or the even lines or the
odd lines now because it has all been
doing with analog equipment you couldn't
store the image and send the odd lines
and send the even light at the same
point in time so when you capture the
odd lines here this would start at time
zero when you start capturing the even
lines it's a fifty of a second later
so you're capturing this twenty
milliseconds later and so on so each
field is sampled at a different point in
time so you've got 50 discrete images
captured but each of them only has half
the number of lines and they have a
different half in there that's fine and
you transmit that you can record that on
to analog video tape you can transmit it
you could do all sorts of processing
with it until you start coming to put it
into computers and because what happened
was is that people started to treat it
all the same well actually people still
talked about things being 25 frames per
second in the UK they never were they
were always 50 fields per second so any
gets pushed into the computer your
computer will catch
the first mod field and it will capture
the second even field and it will start
to interlace them back together to
create a single frame if you've got the
odd things in that in the actual image
and it puts them together and it stores
them in the QuickTime file in the avi
whatever it is you're using at 25 frames
per second now that's fine because you
could then play them back out of your
capture card and mid-90s back onto a TV
and it looked files because it wouldn't
pick them and send them out in the right
order the problem comes if you then try
and display that image directly on
screen in that because things are moving
between each of those things you get the
sort of little zigzag effects because
actually this letter T here is moving
horizontally so each time it's captured
the lines at a different point so when
you're interlocked them you get that
sort of combing effect on the edge it's
a pain how do you display it properly
you do ask difficult questions so what
do you have to do well first of all you
need to think about it not as being a
single frame that you interlace back
together but actually being separate
frames so if we have the lines along
here and we have time along here so
we've got 0 there we've got field 1 here
field to here field 3 here field 4 field
5 on point 0 we're capturing let's say
we're doing this with the odd ones we
capture these lines here then at point 1
we're actually capturing the bits in the
middle we're capturing that bit
capturing that bit capturing that bit
capturing that bit then at point two
we're capturing the there and so on and
point three we're capturing here it here
what they're trying to do with interlace
is to reduce the amount of information
they need to transmit so you could have
think of it perhaps as a bit like us of
earlier analog compression system a bit
like mp3 reduces the amount of
information needs to be stored to store
some audio interlace is doing the same
thing with video it's reducing the
amount of information but hopefully it's
not throwing away anything that you're
going to see so for something static
like a video image of this book very
little is lost bike
as meeting in an interview a storm over
a nine interlaced or progressive form
was it be called we'd still see all that
pretty much all the detail we see
between the two so we reduce the amount
of information we need to transmit by
half but we're still effectively
transmitting what looks the same to the
end-user when they're viewing it on
their television screen certainly at the
time when this was developed but we're
still throwing information away every
sample point refering away half the
information we could possibly have
captured there and actually what we're
throwing away is the separation between
vertical resolution I how much detail we
can represent and also temporal
resolution what we've got here is this
is a single capture point 2.0 we capture
all the odd lines point 1 we capture all
the even lines now think about something
like the piece of paper I am capturing
here so point 0 I capture this line here
which is white and this lunch is all
white and so on all the way down so
effectively what we capture at each
point on here is a completely white
field at this point though we capture
this line which is green then we capture
this line which is also green and we
capture this line which is also green
and at this point you're done we capture
a completely green field the next point
of time we go back and capture a
completely white field and then we
capture a completely green field and if
you were to display this what you would
see would not be a series of white and
green lines but actually the image
flashing between white and green we've
got to a situation where yes we've
reduced the amount of information that
we need to transmit but we've also
manipulated the information so that we
cannot distinguish between high
resolution vertical information
did Siri just help try to help yep I'm
sorry Siri you can't do a computer file
yet so effectively what we've got is
we've mapped both the high frequency
vertical information and also temporal
information into the same part of the
encoding of the information as though
there's no easy way to distinguish
between the two so high frequency
information like this oscillating white
and green pattern is indistinguishable
once we've interlaced it from a flashing
white and green screen there's just no
way you can deal with that the way you
get round this is that inside the camera
when you sample the information you
filter it vertically so that you don't
have that high-resolution image there so
effectively an interlaced camera it's
got a slightly lower vertical resolution
and the progressive one would had but
probably around 70 percent of the
vertical information is still there
still better than you'd get if you only
transmitted a smaller number of lines
every frame so it gives you the benefit
but this still comes down to thing how
on earth do we display interlaced
material on something like a computer
which has an inherently progressive
display without getting all the sort of
zig zaggy patterns
well it's not an easy it's not an easy
problem to solve it can be in some
situations so there's some of the
situations where it can be really easy
to deal with
for example film translated onto a video
film shot at 25 frames per second as we
talked about in the other one when that
is transferred onto videotape is that
you take the piece of film you scan the
odd-numbered lines
transmit that as a field you scan the
even numbered lines transmitted as a
field then move on to the next frame so
actually those point the two fields do
come from the same point in time so
actually the best way to knit them back
together is literally to weave them
together though and you get the same
film frame that you started with all the
representation of it you get all the
detail so that's the best way to do it
for film material now some of my videos
we've seen on the computer screen that
doesn't work what you need to do
is actually only have information that
should be at point zero
displayed there and I've only have
information at point one displayed here
and only have information at point two
displayed here how on earth you go about
that well there's several ways you could
do it you could just say well okay I
know it's going to fill in this gap here
so what I'll do is I'll interpolate
between line 1 and line 3 to work out
what line 2 would be so I'll just use
the information at that point in time
and just create a sort of as that's the
thing there and then I'll do the same
between 3 & 5 between 5 & 7 and so on
the problem that happens here is that
you immediately reduce the resolution
down to only being as high as the number
of lines you've got in a field so is
there any way you can do this well yeah
basically what you want to do is to
generate the information that would have
been there if the cameras captured it at
that point and the way you can do that
is not just use the line above on the
line below but also realize that you
know what was in that point 50/50 for
the second before and you could also
know what's in that point 50 of a second
in the future if you delayed everything
by a single field so what we do instead
of actually trying to generate this
frame here at point 2 we store it
digitally which we can do in the
computer quite easily until we get to
0.3 at which point we've already seen
this information so we can use that
we've got this information because it's
just arrived and we've got these two
bits of information and we can combine
all that together to generate the data
that should be at this point and the
data that should be at this point and so
on so we delay the video by a field or
two fields and similar we now have more
information we've got something that's
in the future from the point we're
generating we've got the information
that's in the past that we've already
seen and the information that's on
different lines as well we can combine
all that in various different
complicated algorithms to generate the
information and the more expensive your
equipment the clever the algorithm will
be and the better it will do and so if
we were to enable one of them on our
computer and VLC which is what I'm using
here it's got several built in then I'm
going to Nabal yet another deinterlacing
algorithm
and if I turn it on you will see
suddenly instead of being zig zaggy it
goes back to being straightforward text
most TVs these days are LCD panels or
whatever maybe plasma so are they doing
this kind of stuff all the time then or
do they use a different method note them
so they're doing this inside every LCD
you'll get there will be a chip which
will be taking the video and processing
it to produce progressive video from the
interlaced video that's coming in and
depending on how much you pay for that
chip whether it's a 50 P chip or 75 P
chip and that 50 P is the price not than
the resolution of the video is producing
it depends 50 pence chip or 50 cents
because it's probably worth more these
days then you are going to get a better
quality algorithm hopefully you have one
that's reprogram or but that cost even
more money
so that's that's why we get jaggedy
lines and that's how you potentially fix
it no you didn't think it was going to
be that simple did you all right let's
go back to things so with the video
signal coming in is a series of fields
green and then so we've got a bit later
on we move it up show the next one and
so on and so by doing that fast enough
you get the appearance of motion